はじめのナレーション（以下，「ナ」）：youtubeの動画には
ナ：コメント欄が有る。
ナ：YouTube上のいろんな動画に
ナ：様々なコメントが有るが最近はよく…
ナ：コメントの中でのケンカが，見かけられる
ナレーションでないはじめ（以下，「は」）はぁ…（ため息）
ナ：もし，このコメントが、実際に「人間」だったら…
ナ：どーなっているんだ
ナ：私は，想像してみた
コメントを読む人（以下，コ）：はじめん，今日誕生日なんだ
コ：祝ってくれ！頼む！別コメ：　・・・狙うな
コ：おめでとっ　別コ：はじめんじゃないけどおめでと
おめでとう
コ：みんな・・・「祝え」とは言っているけど，「高評価しろ」とは言ってないぞ。
コ：私昨日誕生日やった(≧∇≦)b　別コ：おめでとー　は（！！）：おめでと　別コ：しゃちょー・・・
コ：本物じゃん（驚いていると思う）　別コ：マジしゃちょークソワロタｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
コ：きっとコメ主にとって，とてもうれしい(≧∇≦)b誕生日になったよ。
コ：ピースピース✌　別コ：しねっ（字幕追加人「・・・」）　別コ：私も誕生日！！
コ：病院行けば？　別コ：お前が死ね　別コ：みんな・・・ありがとう！(≧∇≦)b　別コ：死ね
コ：はじめんありがとう！（小声で「いえーいおにいちゃんピースピース」）
コ：いえーい！！！！！！！！
コ：いきなり死ねって言われてもね・・・（字幕追加人：たしかに。まず死ねはありえない。とても不快）
コ続き：アカウント作る前にお母さんに許可貰った？
続き：小学生が，YouTubeなんかでアカウント作っちゃだめだよ
続き：漢字読めないの忘れてた。（ちょっぴりバカにしてる感じ（？））お母さんに読んでもらってね
コ：よかったね！
コ：そういうあおり方も，よっぽど小学生みたいだ
コ：おお！自分は明後日，誕生日なんです。　別コ：あらかわいいｶﾜ(・∀・)ｲｲ!!　別コ：ドロップデッド
コ：死ね×２１
コ：おめでとう　別コ：そんなコメントで返信貰おうとしているのかな？？？
コ：カマチョワロタ（ﾜﾛﾀﾝﾊﾞﾘﾝ（ｒｙ）ってディスられてしまうよ？？？
コ：みなさーん，登録者五百人目指して動画投稿やってます！先輩にゴキブリぶちまけたりしてます。ぜひ見に来て下さい。　別コ：しね
コ：うそ・・・私も今日誕生日です。
コ：おめでとう　別コ：暴言しか言えない（効果音「ﾋﾟ-----ｯ！！」）小学生はロムってなさい
コ：おめれとうです。何かいいことがるといいですね！　別コ：ありがとうございます。
コ：（呆れた口調で）こういうの最近多いよね・・・　別コ：おめでとう
コ：ハッピーバースディ！
コ：よかったらチャンネル登録お願いします
コ：おめでとうございます。私もあと少しで誕生日，ワクワク((o(´∀｀)o))ﾜｸﾜｸ
コ：おっめ～・・・でももう誕生日終わっちゃうね。
おめでとうございます。　別コ：確かに！ただのカマチョワロタｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
コ：おめでとう
コ：こういうのは気にしないほうがいいよ。ただのカマチョだから
続き：あと（言えないよっ（効果音ﾋﾟｰｰｰｯ））でもあるなｗ
コ：おっめ～　別コ：おめえが死ねよ
コ：お前がキモいよ
コ：カマチョかよｗ
コ：気にしないで。　別コ：はじめんじゃないけど日にちが変わる前に・・・おめでとう！
コ：そう，それな。　別コ：死ねしか言えないんですよ。この人は。
数人：おめでとう（まじで，おめでとさんなどが入る）
コ：ラインとかツイッターでやれよ。ここは動画のコメントをするところだぞ
コ：「おめでとう」とか言っている奴らも，そんなこと言うから，コメ主がつけあがるんだよ。
コ：なんかｺﾞﾒﾝﾅｻｲm(_ _)m。でもはじめん本人も「おめでとう」って言ってたよ？
コ：うるさいハゲ
コ：小学生はアカウント作っちゃだめなんだよ？
続き：明日学校なんだろ？寝とけよがき！
コ：はじめん本人から何かしらコメント
もらえるのは嬉しいけど，場をわきまえろってことっ
コ：おめでと～
はじめん：高評価とチャンネル登録よろしくね～！！！